So let's discuss the answer to our laptop
falls down quiz. For the pavement, the failure is
whatever causes the pavement to no longer perform its
function properly. Here, you might be tempted to say
that it needs to be replaced is the failure.
But actually that's the repair of the failure. This
is fixing the pavement, it's not something that causes
it to deviate from its function. Really, it breaking,
causing it to need to be replaced, so
breaking is the failure. What's the fault? It's the
event that resulted in the first error. In
this case, it's not that the laptop fell out
of the bag, it had nothing to do with the pavement. Is it that the laptop hits
the pavement. And now what was the first error?
Well, it was that the pavement developed a crack.
The structure, the internal behavior of the pavement
is no longer the same as the proper
pavement. But we really notice this in terms
of deviating from its specified function when it
broke. So we can still use a pavement with a crack. The crack expanded, so the
error became bigger, but really until it broke,
the pavement was functioning properly. So this is what
we get at the end.